listen seriously okay I was watching you
and I was like does she know the words
that are coming out of her mouth you
look so genuinely shocked so God still
don't know what I said I think I I knew
I forgot to thank my freaking cast we'll
do it here come on just extraordinary
cast every single one of them are
Duplass at Steve Carell really Crudup
karen pittman Google and Barbara Bell
Polly Deshawn Janina Nestor and that's a
lot big cast yes Oh Nancy banks who is
my incredible coach who made I've never
never knew I could love acting like I'm
doing another speech you know how we are
you know how much we all root for you
and so seeing this was really like
I'll get this big grin on her face like
she did it was so excited and this is
like your first time back at the party
in such a long time so what a welcome
was it lovely welcome back it's been a
long time and that's why I meant when I
said you know I know when this when I
can't find it into this room it's really
special because it's my it's my beers
everybody was rooting for you
back here yeah definitely so
[Music]